what are you doing now that's different
with uh you know you got on a Twitter
right and so I know that and
congratulations I think because it's
interesting it's brave for people to get
out of the system a lot of people I was
expelled from the system but oh yeah
yeah well you know you got you got laid
off from everywhere was it cutbacks or
why did you think cutbacks no good I
love I'm I'm going to use that though
there's downsizing just downsizing yeah
I'm being retrained I'm learning to code
actually
they closed the plant I totally get I
was on third shift and there just the
demand was in Decline um I am going to
use that though next time why were you
fired but you got out and you moved to
uh I was thrown out thrown out and I and
Elon called me the day that I my show
was cancelled and um and I was grateful
that he did and he called you huh had
you spoken to him before yeah yeah yeah
okay yeah he I had and uh and I really
liked him and um I'm not a technology
person to put in my ly like at all very
an technology yep like almost on a crazy
sort of Ted kazinski way which is I'm
not defending it's so who handles tech
for you then kind of the tech people I
don't they they live in Bangalore I
don't know their names just kidding no
we have really super smart people the
bangalorian is the
bangalorian no um actually our
Mandalorian most of our staff from Fox
came um and elon's I we don't work for
Elon I'm just I'm a Twitter user like
everybody else but his all he said was
um I'm going to keep the platform open
you know and people with differing views
whether agree with them or not are
welcome on the platform and and that's
that's the guarantee that I wanted and
needed and so I've been super grateful I
mean that's all I've ever wanted by the
way um is to I've never been a I have
made some money but not never got crazy
rich but I never wanted to that wasn't
my goal at all I mean I guess I would
like to be richer I guess I don't know
what I would do with it exactly I just
don't want to be bossed around and by
the way I don't mind taking advice or
wise counsel from people I respect or
I'm often wrong I'm not saying that I'm
always right I'm definitely not but
being ordered to do things suggests a
level of disrespect I just can't I just
can't deal with it at all and even just
about like work and stuff were you
always like that from just like with
work like you want to be your own voice
of course yeah I mean where you end up
right keep getting fired right yeah yeah
I mean not that I don't I don't want to
fight about it not interested in being
like you can't tell me what to do or you
know give a lot of lectures about it but
I I def especially in my business you
have a similar job where you know you're
paid to say what you think yeah right
and so you you want to do your job which
is to say what you think was there even
a time when you were working at
different news places where you were
like gosh this still isn't my own voice
oh all the time really was always my own
voice but there just you could feel the
parameters I mean I started in my 20s
mid 20s I'm now in my mid-50s so it's
been a long time why you look great for
50s man I'm 54 are you really yes oh wow
I know isn't that shocking shocking I
don't feel it but anyway but when you're
when you're much younger and you've got
little kids I always had a lot of kids
just reproduce like a crazy person yeah
which I recommend strongly to you um you
know you feel vulnerable and like you
know you're not allowed to say certain
things and I do think I I was never
censored but I self-censored for sure
you know
the war rock breaks out and you're like
maybe it's a good
idea but it's not a good idea and you
know it's not a good idea yeah you know
what I mean but you allow yourself to be
convinced because you know it's super
unpopular to say it's not a good idea
but it clearly wasn't war with Iran not
a good idea I can say that now why do we
go along with that consensus a lot of
times what is it that makes us afraid to
speak out well people have a deep need
to be part of a group it's just it's a
human need right up there with sex and
food and shelter you know it's like
people want to be connected to other
people which I understand and and I want
that too but that can override reason
and Common Sense very often so if you're
I know million studies been done on this
but if you're in a group I mean everyone
experienc you're in a group full of
people and everyone's like you know I
hate chocolate ice cream and you're like
I kind of like chocolate ice cream but
you don't say anything about it cuz
people like chocolate ice cream suck and
you're like yeah they kind of suck you
know it's just it's a human thing and um
so it's people go along with stuff that
their gut tells them isn't the right
thing but you should never ignore your
gut your instincts which you inherited
from your ancestors which are encoded in
your DNA and which are almost never
wrong if you're with someone and you
feel like God that person's lying that
person's lying you may not know what
about you don't have X-ray vision into
someone's soul but you can smell the
deception on someone I know that you can
we all can oh yeah or if you feel danger
you're like wow this person poses a
threat to me you're
right you don't know the details you
don't need to know the details get away
and if something's really stupid like
let's go war with Ron it's like what
yeah and I just feel like it's you know
maybe because of my age and my job I I
have a moral obligation to say I I think
that's really unwise you don't want to
you don't want to go to war with Iran no
because I'm not insane so what is your
plans now like you've already you're on
Twitter you're in a free space as much
as we have in in today's society you're
in a free space for free speech what
else do you is there like
we have some plans I mean some of them I
mean if I'm being honest include
territorial expansion we're going to
invade Canada oh dude they'll just knock
no pillow fight you take them in a
second um no I mean I I I just want to
continue doing what we're doing which is
just you know say say things that can't
be said in other places bring facts that
maybe people haven't heard with a spirit
of humility you know if you I'm having
spent my whole life in Washington most
of it 35 years I'm very I know it's I
can't believe I but you know what I
think a lot of people were glad that
somebody was there you know it's nice to
see people that get out of a space
because then they're when you're not as
compromis when people don't seem as
compromised it's totally right no it's
totally true but I didn't realize just
how controlled my brain was by it when I
was in it because you don't right but um
but anyway but I've been around a lot of
people who set out like with these
grandiose plans I'm going to change the
World those people invariably 100% of
the time make the world worse so like
you know approach every task with the
knowledge I have no real idea what I'm
doing I don't know the long-term
consequences of this I probably can't
fix every problem I'm just going to try
my best with humility you know to make
things slightly better that's my goal
make things slightly better but anyone
who tells you if we pass this
legislation we're going to fix
everything we're going to fix health
healthare forever said Barack Obama in
2010 as soon as he said that I was like
I don't even know much about Healthcare
I'm hardly an expert but I was like the
second you tell me you're going to fix
something as complicated as you know one
of the entire US economy in one piece of
legislation you yeah cuz you're
lying actually because that's impossible
and it turned out they made it worse of
of course so I don't want to do that not
that I even have the power to but I just
want to you know I just want to tell the
truth and and do it without
being told not to and I think that we
can and Tucker on X is your show y right
Y and do you guys have will you do you
think would you ever do a show with a
partner you think or anything like that
I'm not going to pit you an idea I'm
just uh because that's usually the
predecessor question of like somebody
trying to pit you an idea but do you
think about that sort of thing like do
you have I well I mean I have a million
people I would like to to work with I
mean you know I like to interview people
actually and a lot and I really try to
be quiet while I interview them because
I'm a compulsive talker obviously but
I'd like a rest bit from that where I
can just like listen so I like to we
will have a lot of people on and we have
and we'll have a lot of recurring guests
but yeah we have all we're making a
bunch of documentaries and doing stuff
like that um so like a production
company kind of more like are you
expanding in that sense MH
yep